guy reached out to me and he says hey
you said you don't know how to get to a
billion I want to give you some advice
he says with no businesses right and I'm
like dude first off aw like point one
but the second point is I said not that
I don't know how to but I would never
say I know how to until him there and
then I'll say this is how I did it and
here's the Nuance it's not like here's
how you do it or here's how to do it
here's how I did it no one can fight you
on that it's like saying you should have
oatmeal for breakfast versus I had
oatmeal for breakfast no one can fight
meal I had oatmeal for breakfast I had
oatmeal for breakfast as soon as you
start projecting and preaching and doing
the shs and finger waving that's when
everyone hates you